Right. So, I think we have the uh first
members of the audience uh joining. So,
welcome. And uh while we're waiting for
everyone else to to join as well. uh on
behalf of the uh organizing committee of
uh connected data world I'd like to
welcome you all to today's session uh in
which we're going to uh look at um some
usually deep tech uh matters in uh
hopefully in a different lens so uh more
u from market point of view so my name
is George Anadotis I'm actually a member
of the organiza organizing team of
connected data world and I'm going to uh
tell you a little bit about myself but
first uh the polite thing to do is
actually to introduce the people in the
uh the panel with me tonight. So in no
particular order uh simply uh in the
order I see them in the in this gallery
view. I'm going to start by uh Bob Bob
Flout who is the uh uh founder and CEO
co-founder and CEO of uh semi
technologies and uh Bob if you'd like to
say a few words about yourself.
>> Yeah so first of all thank you for
having me. So I'm indeed co-founder of
semi technologies. um we create an open-
source uh uh factor search engine called
uh weate and um graph connections play a
big role in the in the search engine. So
I'm looking forward to the discussion
tonight. Thank you for having me.
>> Great. Thanks Bob. And then let's
continue this uh clockwise I guess uh
round of introduction. So uh next in
round is Panos Papadopoulos from
Marathon VC.
>> Uh hello all. I'm a partner at Marathon
Venture Capital where we invest
predominantly in developer tools and
enterprise productivity. Before that was
an entrepreneur uh with experience
mostly in the big data space not so much
in connected uh but that's a repeating
issue we're seeing now with startups
that they try to create essentially
knowledge graphs and tools to help us
make sense of the world.
>> Great. Thanks Panos. And then last but
not least, we have uh Constantine from
Runa Capital.
>> Hi everybody. It's pleasure to be here
today. Uh I represent Runa Capital. We
are investing at early stages in tech
companies including a lot of data
related companies. And I personally
focus on enterprise software, machine
learning applications, open source cloud
infrastructure and other kind of related
things.
>> Great. So yeah, after this first round
of introduction, I guess uh my turn to
say a few words about myself. So besides
uh well organizing this uh this entire
event, um I also do a number of things
uh including writing. So I write for
ZDNet and venture bit. I also do uh
consulting and I work as an analyst as
well. So that's [snorts] uh that's many
uh that's a lot of hats to wear. uh
which is why um it allows me to look at
things in many different ways and that's
also the motivation for for organizing
this uh this session today. I thought
that while there is by now enough uh
technology let's say analysis in this
space uh I thought that maybe um what
was a bit missing was um a more uh
market oriented point of view and this
is why uh I thought it would be a good
idea to get together uh a panel of
people some of which have uh investment
experience so so from they're on the
investor side of things and uh while Bob
on the other hand is u is is an
entrepreneur. Uh he has a startup which
has received uh investment. So uh
together we're trying to uh demystify
let's say uh this uh this entire space.
But uh the first thing to do is actually
to to try and define it. So uh what do
we mean uh by uh by connected data? And
since I'm at least um co-responsible,
let's say for uh for coining the term, I
may as well start by uh explaining um
referencing let's say the what we see as
uh in connected data, what we see as the
the four pillars of this of this
category. So um uh when people ask me uh
so you know what what is connected data
all about and actually I gave a
presentation recently which was
precisely about that uh what I usually
try to do is uh give a quick uh timeline
let's say so if you if you start in uh
chronological order uh you could say
that probably the first uh pillar would
be uh graph analytics and you know the
the story there uh the usual story that
many of you uh may have heard goes back
to the 18th century when uh this uh
brilliant scientist named Leonard Doer
was trying to come up with a way to uh
cross bridges in uh in an optimal manner
let's say and that led to the
development of graph theory and graph
analytics that are used in in many use
case today. Uh the next uh the next uh
step let's say in that uh journey would
be uh quite a few years later actually.
So um for me that's the um the semantic
web which was uh conceived let's say um
in the early uh 2000s
and that was also the time when the
first graph databases were um were
crafted as uh as the need uh arose to uh
to store uh those those triples uh RDF
triples that uh semantic web uh
introduced and then fast forwarding a
little bit to today and that's that's
also by the way uh the um the core the
essence let's say of of knowledge graphs
and fast forward fast forwarding a
little bit to today uh we also have
graph machine learning which is uh uh
the latest and according to many people
the most promising let's say um sub uh
subdomain of uh machine learning. So
those are uh the four technological
areas let's say that uh we think uh
comprise uh this uh this domain.
Uh so the next
>> [snorts]
>> uh part let's say after having uh
defined those would be to try and um and
see how they're interesting where they
uh where they interact with how they
interact with each other and um how we
could possibly define the uh the market
let's say for uh for each of those. Um I
would start probably let's let's do this
in in in the order that uh that uh the
that we introduce them. So let's start
with uh with graph analytics and uh try
to see what what use cases we uh we may
have there and by doing so uh we may be
able to uh to get a feeling of uh the
applicability let's say and therefore uh
the market. So anyone would like to uh
to address that to pick that up and
share some some use cases and some some
ideas with us.
or if you feel shy um I I can't do that
but
>> no [clears throat]
happy to say a few words out of what we
know out of practice so what we see
especially about the last pillar that
you mentioned George is the um uh the
graph machine learning um right is that
from a horizontal perspective if if I
look at the use cases that we are
currently um gathering
there's there are literally and I mean
is this in the positive sense of the
word they're all over the place. So it's
like it doesn't matter if it's finance,
medical, um smaller startups, bigger
enterprises. So it really feels that um
this type of technology that it came to
a point where people really can use it
in production. So that it's like it's
out of the promise and it's moving into
a production stage. So it's like um then
that's not really answering your
question because you were asking like
how big is the market? Well, I if I had
to guess, I think this will be following
like the data warehouse market. So, um
as as a comparison, so the data
warehouse problem is solved and I I make
air quotes because of course it's
software so we can always improve it.
But it's like people figured it out. We
know what the what the importance is of
it. And I think that these kinds of uh
linked data regardless on how you define
it use cases but especially when it
comes to um when it includes machine
learning
um it's just it's it's all over if you
have data there's a there there is a a a
problem that can be solved mostly
related to search um indexing and those
kind of things.
>> Yeah. Actually I was not as ambitious or
maybe foolish to to believe that we
could uh somehow define let's say the uh
total addressable market here but I was
more thinking of well if we um if we can
maybe highlight the most prominent use
cases that would give us an
approximation let's say a rough estimate
of well how how many use cases are there
and therefore how much how big the
market may be. Yeah, I think uh comment
here is that even the technologies
around for some year, you know, we have
seen predominantly the data world being
dominated by DBMS because essentially
the BMS is modeling very simplistic
operations simplistic like compared to
the physical world uh inside enterprises
right so it's like a order book or a
customer list and of course those can
have huge complexity uh but as we now
see like modeling the physical world uh
we start seeing that you know our BMSS
have created there they were never made
to be making so complex queries. So some
examples that we are seeing is one
predominantly in computational chemistry
in computational biology right so we
have entities that interact in many
different ways with other entities
inside the body or inside the molecules
uh and it's kind of possible to keep
those relationships like in their own
tables. uh so we start seeing a great
deal of applications of grad databases
to create essentially knowledge that
knowledge databases where you can go and
query I'm going to jump into a
demonstration later from one of our
portfolio companies of how you can
navigate the complex world of realities
where everything is interconnected
another space where we're seeing a lot
of adoption of graph databases is in the
financial world you can imagine all
sorts of trades interacting entities
they have different interests uh they
have several different contracts and
when you also need to to understand
who's behind what entities a lot of
financial entities now are using graph
databases to be able to do uh AML so to
understand who is the beneficial owner
of a cascading list of entities that are
dominating the current the current world
uh if it's fine I can uh share my screen
where I can show for example two cases
of using graph databases behind and the
scene that make it extremely easy for
people uh who interact with them. So the
point of course as with any great
software is not like to burden the end
users uh with all the intricacies of a
database uh but also they expose just
the bits that are related to graph in
terms of visualizations and in terms of
doing uh queries on graphs which is also
very a very different topic that most
people are not used to.
>> Yeah. Yeah. By all means, I mean, if if
you want to share something now, yeah,
feel free.
>> Okay. Um, so let me choose another tab.
Uh, okay. So, this is Coali. Coali is
one of our investments here at SmartBC.
And what Coali does is that is parsing
uh huge corpuses of biomedical,
literature, scientific
uh they do clinical studies uh and also
private resources. So as you can
understand in there there are multiple
of entities that they can understand
through NLP. Uh so for example you know
there are genes, cells, molecules,
viruses,
drugs and so on and all of these things
all of these entities are interacting in
a very intricate web of different
relationships. So you know what will be
you know the very uh hot topic today is
what are the symptoms of COVID right? Uh
typically uh if you use PubMet and you
search for COVID 19, you're going to see
like a list uh you're going to search
for COVID 19, you're going to see like
uh a list of articles like you know and
you have to read them to understand
what's going on. Uh this doesn't scale
very well. It doesn't scale for people.
Uh the literature is expanding is
actually blowing up and there is no way
to be able to use like traditional
search to match documents and read
absolutely everything. So what does uh
they have parsed all the all the all the
literature they have recognized
different entities and now they can give
us a user interface that's giving us
like the graph of for example how we go
from a covid-19 virus to the disorders I
can also search for the physiology or
procedures to be coorbidities and then
go into the symptoms so of course we all
know co
uh causes fever. I can see how I got
there through the different uh through
the graph and then they will point me at
where exactly it was noted. Now that's a
very easy example right uh what I would
like to do u is to be able to understand
now more complex topics right so more
complex topics as I said you know they
are better uh
they are better uh visualized in a graph
so something which is I thought it was
like bogus science is that actually
vinegar
what we all know can help you to reduce
your glucose in the blood
Mhm.
>> Uh so very easy everything is powered by
uh by Neo forj and of course if my
glucose changes maybe then my insulin
resistance is going to be reduced. So is
this sorry I didn't type it well is is
this true or is it not? So as you can
see now when I type insulin coselli is
going to give me different
u categories of what insulin could be
right. uh and I'm looking here for
a situation where it's resistance with a
pathologic function. So now I can do
this query as you can see in a graph
database that people do know right but
I'm looking here for causality this an
of causality uh is vinegar causing
glucose to do something that then causes
a change in insulin resistance. This is
the query I'm making. And as you can see
here, it tells me that vinegar
downregulates glucose. So it's reducing
uh uh its levels which leads to higher
insulin resistance and I can see that in
a network right so this is a very simple
network perhaps I should try something
more complex. If for example you know I
choose all concepts of glucose. You can
see now that this becoming a bit more
complex and I can navigate this graph to
see all the different connections and of
course and then I can dive into just in
the relationships that I'm interested
just by looking uh by diving into and
looking then and reading the biography
uh sorry the biography I mean the the
bibliography. Uh
so that's that's what I had to share for
now.
Okay. Okay. Cool. That's that's an
interesting uh use case. And actually uh
it sort of touches upon uh something
that uh well I was thinking that we we
would maybe drill down to a little bit
later but we may as well bring it up
now. So uh the interesting point uh that
I see there is that uh this is actually
a very it's a it's a very interesting
use case first of all and it's one that
actually sort of built let's I would I
would say on on deep tech. So uh it's um
a use case in uh in uh biio medicine I
guess that has been built on top of a
graph database. So you have the deep
tech layer and then you have different
different commercial use cases and uh
since it's uh sharing time I guess uh
before we get into this distinction and
how um from the investment point of view
um this may be interesting I would also
like to uh share something which well I
guess um many people will be familiar
with but I want to show it anyway. Um
and that is since we mentioned uh graph
databases and I hope you can uh see my
screen. So this is the um the trend uh
chart for uh actually for all databases
uh including graph databases and as you
can see there's a very clear um leader
let's say in terms of uh trend here and
that is graph databases. uh you can see
that relational has been kind of
stalling let's say for for many years
now while on the other hand uh the
growth on graph databases is quite quite
phenomenal actually it's um just off the
charts really that doesn't necessarily
mean something in terms of uh you know
market value and capitalization and all
of that but it's it's an indication and
this is why I'm I'm bringing it up and
yeah just just wanted to uh to show
that. So, um perhaps that's a good um uh
conversation starter, let's say, to get
a little bit more into the uh specifics.
So, I'd like to ask uh you actually
Constantin. So, what do you think? Um
so, we saw already uh the overall uh
trend, let's say, for for graph
databases. And we already saw um a very
interesting uh use case, a very
interesting startup actually that is
building on on graph databases. So um
where do you think as an investor is um
is the most interesting aspect right now
in this space. So would you be looking
to invest in deep tech uh companies or
would you be looking to invest in um use
cases in startups that build use cases
such as the one that Pano showed us
previously. Well, there are plenty of
use cases and probably would like to
continue a thought of panas about uh
potential applications of graph graph
database. Actually there are two kinds
of data in the world generated by humans
and generated by nature and nature is
already very complex and that's why you
need graph databases in chemistry in
drug discovery other kind of uh complex
fields and uh humanity also generated
enough data for last dozens of years
stored it in relational databases or
other kind of tradition more traditional
types of databases and now it's time to
work with this complexity which was
created Now it's time for graph
databases. Frankly speaking, I think
that in terms of technology, we already
have enough good companies on the
market, but we lack a good applications
of these technologies for some specific
areas like which was already shown today
in medical space and there are plenty of
other spaces which I found very
promising. One of them for example is
sales acceleration tools. Actually if we
just think about sales uh B2B sales it's
very simple thing you just to deliver
some information about your product to
some relevant people at relevant
organizations which will turn into sales
in your contracts but there are plenty
of different tools helping to do such
kind of this kind of work and they all
cover a very small segment of of this
job but by the end of the day you have
kind of B2B universe right you have a
number of entities in the world, legal
entities and number of people working at
these entities and these enterprises and
it this data is stored in different
government ledgers other kind of data
but by the end of the day this is a
graph and
somebody who could just collect this
data and connect it properly turned into
real graph covering all these relations
between people and organization could
build ultimate sales tool
and uh build probably 10 billion dollar
company on top of it or maybe a $100
billion company if if it's done
properly. It's one of the stories.
Another um particular segment which I'm
excited about is blockchain because
blockchain is also just a graph uh in
just number of objects connected with
each other with different relations and
uh immutable ledger of operations on top
of them and there for example chain
analysis which is doing just graph
analytics on top of blockchain and it's
worth more than $1 billion I believe
there will be more such use cases uh for
specific structured data like blockchain
or there will be um just new companies
applying existing graph technologies on
top of connected data from different
ledgers and say more traditional data
sources.
Mhm. So um you have a clear preference
it seems for not for not so much for
vendors let's say so technologies that
that so for companies that provide the
technology but for companies that use
that uh deep tech let's say to to build
on on use cases. So in that respect uh
what's your opinion about the um the
fragmentation let's say that uh
currently exists in this graph database
market but also more more broadly in the
uh connected data market. So if if we
just stay to graph databases uh speaking
from experience as I have just recently
done an analysis there I think there are
maybe over 30 vendors at uh at this
point which is probably a little bit too
much. So um off the record many people
uh many people who are um executives
actually in in graph database vendors uh
they all say well you know it's a bit
too too much and we expect to see a
consolidation uh soon. Do you think that
that makes sense? Well, it could happen.
Frankly speaking, we track a lot of the
open source databases and I can't see
any graph database among top 10
databases by number for example of
active contributors in the world right
now. I think uh the time for let's say
uh number one and number two graph
databases is still to come. I mean
they're they're not so popular as
relational databases or transactional or
analytical database like click house or
MongoDB or other kind of more
traditional players. I think um graph
database market is at very early stage
of its development and we could see few
u clear winners maybe focus on different
use cases where they show their
competitive advantages. Yeah, I think
the fragmentation uh the vendor
fragmentation is not that important
because in DBMS we can see that you know
there are the basis on a list of the
basis and they all harness SQL and
pretty much you know it's mostly
standardized and the last product the
first standardization of SQL happened in
the 80s so far we have kind of failed to
see like a winning uh query language or
graph of the basis and perhaps graphql
which is more now popular even for other
use cases might be perhaps you know one
of the way that you know we get like uh
the holy grail for at least you know
being able to interact with them uh so I
think the biggest recommendation for me
is mostly uh on the tooling and the
interface rather than the vor itself
>> well on graphql is an interesting point
actually and uh well one that I can't
can't resist sort of jumping in well It
is true that it's being adopted across
the board on by by many uh by many
databases in general. So regardless of
whether they're relational or uh or
anything else and many products in fact
I see uh Bob waving there and he Bob
you're you're next up and you're going
to be telling us exactly how you use
GraphQL because it's it's an interesting
use case that you have but just for the
record while you know it's very useful
and very popular and all of those things
it's not really a graph query language
so you can do lots of things with
GraphQL but not so not really graph
queries So with that, I'll I'll actually
pass on to to you Bob because you're
using that in your product and it's it
[snorts] would be interesting to uh to
know how.
>> Yeah. So uh yeah. Yeah, that that's
that's a good point and actually to
start with your last point that is
actually true. So I think what's
important a distinction that's important
to make is that the the difference
between really graph queries that you
want to do so like shortest path
algorithms those kind of things or the
way that you want to structure your data
so that you say like my the data that I
have represents itself as a graph very
similar to what Constantin just said
right so the the like blockchain it's a
form of a graph
um so what we are interested in what
we're working on and that's like where
the machine learning part comes in and I
will also share in a bit how I'll show a
quick demo how graph relates to that is
that if you have a note in the graph you
somehow want to be able to find that
note so you one of the big problems
right now is that if you have a data
object that's been presented as a node
in your graph like how are you going to
find it and what we do is like so we is
called like a vector search engine and
it has a graph data model to model the
data out. That's why we use GraphQL.
Um um is is is very suited for
organizing the data. One thing before I
go in the demo that I just I just want
to mention maybe it's not the most
important thing or for some people it
might be the an important thing but one
thing that GraphQL has which is some
sometimes in my opinion overlooked is
how um intuitive that it is. So I the
demo that I'm going to give you in a bit
is just pure GraphQL and people who are
on the call right now who go like I have
no idea what GraphQL is they will be
able to read it. It's very intuitive and
if I would have to write it in let's say
sparkle it would be a completely
different story. Not saying that there
is not a good reason for that to exist.
It's more like it's a I I personally I
think that the success of GraphQL has to
do with the fact how in like how
intuitive
it is to write it and to and to and to
read it.
>> Uh
>> that's that's a good point about GraphQL
and yeah I was going to say sure um feel
free to uh to do the demo and then
actually after the demo I have a
question for you which uh sort of ties
it all together but let's do the demo.
>> Yeah. So so so let me quickly do that.
So I um uh let me quickly find my my
screen. Here we go. Yes.
Is this uh is this properly sharing?
>> Mhm.
>> Yeah. So what I'm going to do is I'm
going to give you a quick demo. Uh so
the demo that we just seen with the with
the um with the with the graphical
interface, we are a layer lower. So we
are like what one might call deep tech.
So we are the database technology. So
that means that our solution ends on the
level of the database and in our
database you can load or in we can load
any data that you want doesn't matter
what the what the data is but uh for
this specific demo that I'm going to
give I'm going to use Wikipedia. So the
demo that's in this demo data set
contains uh let me quickly see it
contains like uh 11 uh million articles
and 27 million paragraphs. And so if we
look at the perspective of the of the oh
of the paragraph. So I can do something
like this paragraph
and then there are a few things in
there. So let me run it. And this is how
we represent a graph. So this is like
this is pure graphql. So what you see
here this what I selected right now is
one graph uh sorry one note in the graph
that is um uh that is that is
represented. Uh but one of the things
that we can do is that I can say like if
I limit this to the first result. So we
just now see the first paragraph. I can
do something. So I can say well show me
how the machine learning model is
representing this data object in the um
in the graph. So if I run this uh one of
the things that you will see is that
here you see all these coordinates and
that's that's the so-called vector
representation but this is the dimen
highly dimensional space how um the this
note in the graph is uh uh represented
and the reason why that is interesting
is become because we can make relations
based on these um uh um these these
dimensional representations. So let me
take one step back. So again, so this is
the complete Wikipedia with what is it a
little bit over 27 million uh articles,
sorry, paragraphs. So I can do something
like this. I can ask a question. And
what I'm going to try to do is I'm going
to try to find the right note in the
graph. So I can ask a question and I can
say question and I can say like what is
an edge in a graph? just a question and
I going to tell it. I want you to find
the answer in the in the content of the
uh of the paragraph.
I just want to see the first uh the
first result and then I'm going to make
a graph relation where I'm going to say
also show me the article in which you
found this and just show me the title.
So little bit more sophisticated but
we're going to say like okay we're going
to oh and of course we want to see
before I forget we of course want to see
the answer to the question right? So
this is a graph query, GraphQL query
where we're going to ask a natural
language question over the complete
Wikipedia. And if I now run this query,
you see that it results as an abstract
object connecting two graph vertices. So
it found this uh uh data object
in in the graph of 27 million uh um uh
uh data objects and it even went as far
as using the machine learning model to
find the answers in the questions. But
we can also do something like uh let's
say uh well I'm a uh uh uh I'm a big
music fan. So I can say like what was
Frank Zappa's
uh band called? Oh, and now I run run it
again and it says the mothers of
invention. So it found that that that
node in the graph. Um, or you could do
something more specific like for
example, how many people fit in
an air bus
a 380.
So again another uh another query. So
now it's found 656.
So as you can see it found the right
note in the graph. And here 656 seats
838200 was proposed etc. So th this is
like this is what we believe is the next
step in dealing with graphs and
searching with graphs. So we constantly
find these notes. But one of the things
that I can do as well is is um this. So
I can say for example um uh uh uh why is
uh a corona virus
called corona? So you know a little bit
vagger term. So then I run this term and
it's it says like well that's because of
its garland red or crown which is in
this graph notation which is coming from
the article coronavirus disease. But now
I can even go as far as saying like has
uh um oh sorry no not has paragraphs but
um
uh let me quickly oh yeah links to
articles. So now I can make a graph
relation that I can say like okay on
articles which articles does this uh
this um note connect to. So if I run
this query this is a longer query. So
you see it still finds the note with the
right answer based on the question that
I'm asking. It's showing me the content
where it found it in but it even says
like okay these are all the articles on
Wikipedia. this the graph relations that
this data set is uh uh referring to. So
this is an example of one using GraphQL
and secondly how you how machine
learning is directly integrated into the
uh into the graph. So I hope that kind
of answers your question uh George. Um
well I haven't asked the question yet
actually so and it's going to be in a
sort of different direction really. So
my question is actually like I said I'm
trying to tie that all together. So as
you said um what you do is basically on
the on the deep tech level let's say if
we talk on um abstract terms. So
>> that's correct. I'm wondering how were
you able to to pitch that uh to uh to
investors to get uh to get uh funding in
your company? Were for example, would a
demo like the one that you uh showed us
uh be convincing to them? Is that
something like what you did? I'm trying
to think here, you know, and in to to to
wear the shoes, let's say, of people who
may, you know, have potentially uh ideas
they find interesting technologically.
What kind of advice would you give them
to be able to pitch those ideas to uh to
get in investment to to pursue them?
>> Yeah, that is a great question actually
and there are three answers to that. So
answer number one is that we know from
research that 93% of data is
unstructured. So anything that you can
do to improve search through that um
helps. In the case with investors, how
do you do that? Well, you make that
case. So you say like okay this is the
case of 93%.
Um this is what I like to call top down
approach. So you make that case. The
second thing that you do is like you
show a bunch of use cases. So in our
case we have like hundreds of use cases
going into the medical cases going into
the finance cases go into the well all
kinds of cases and say okay so these are
the things that people are building. So
this is how they solving that 93% case.
So for example the example that that
panels just showed we see a lot of
startups using our technology to build
those kind of solutions on top of that
is that is what answer number one. So
what you do is like you show how big the
problem is you you give examples of how
people are using it and then you attach
that to um uh uh the value that you're
trying to create. That's one.
The second way is and that is more if
you talk to more um I like to call it
techsavvy investors is the other way
around.
>> So you start from the bottom up. So you
show this demo what I just showed is
very hard to achieve. Doing these kinds
of machine learning queries finding
these nodes in the graph in milliseconds
in a data set as large as the as
Wikipedia that's hard. and um uh they
know and then often you don't have to
explain how big the problem is because
they already know and they're searching
for companies that aim to solve that.
What is important to bear in mind though
is that the um if you build technology
like we are building which is like what
it's called like deep technology
there's always a distance from the
solution that you build to the end user.
So there always needs to be a company
like if I may give that example panels
like the company that you showed that
use your technology to get to an end
user
>> and anecdotally I would like to say that
uh
we discovered causally by just browsing
primitive website they had and we could
see only see like a graph of going for
example from one substance to its
effects that's it that's all the moment
we saw that was we say okay we need to
find these guys fund them. We didn't
have to say anything else.
>> Basically,
>> I was actually going to ask you
precisely that. So, what what did they
do uh to um to get you on board
basically and I was wondering if you
know they gave you a demo or how did it
work? But it was actually you coming to
them.
>> Yeah, we came to them. They weren't
raising money at the time. Uh they were
mostly working uh some PC's with a top
three pharma company in the world. and
we persuade them to go to to take our
money and go after more customers and
build product faster. U and they're now
doing extremely well. Uh they are
selling to several top health related
institutions, pharma companies, uh
health plans, insurance companies, even
hedge funds. Everybody who needs like to
be able to parse the bibliography in
this uh in this field as we know it's
extremely complicated. It changes very
fast. there's new evidence coming in all
the time and they need a solution like
that. So we are pretty sure that you
know anybody who can give similar demos
in other fields so definitely it's going
to uh have our full intention. I have
seen a a demo from an entrepreneur in
the US that of course we couldn't
invest. Uh they was doing the same thing
for smart for contracts for legal and
insurance and debt contracts and be able
to understand all the entities being
described there. Uh so a bank could just
use it to visualize for example uh you
know how they are exposed to risks and
eventually they could create a graph uh
a weighted graph where they can see you
know uh which pools of capital or what
branches or who people issued depth to
which entities by sector and see where
the risk resides and all of that was
visualized on a graph and they were
using graph database beneath to be able
to make uh these associations
Uh so as I said you know what changes
right now is we have big data but the
point of big data is not just to be like
you know time series or log data. This
is kind of boring to be honest. There
are so many tools that tackle the
problem very well but all these murky
relationships all these uh complex
problems that they have a lot of uh a
network of effects and second order
effects and third order effects cannot
be understood and studied and analyzed
in any other way. uh so I think but the
point is to be able to start from data
sets and build the graph that's the very
tricky part the technology is there but
for example the case of coal you know
they're using a lot of NLP technology
sometimes doesn't have to be like very
advanced NLP and machine learning it has
to be you know some very good huristics
and a good very good definition of the
language people are using when they are
writing biomedical papers uh same thing
could be done for other kind of sources
right the point is how you
deconstruct existing data sets and
create entities and edges.
>> Yeah, I may I add something there
because I one of the things that I
always like to say is that if you look
at the software stack and it also goes
for for example craft technology
is I I like to divide that into three
sections. So at the bottom layer, so the
lowest, the most abstract in the stack,
we have the hardware. And there are
certain hardware providers that are very
good at creating technology
uh uh uh like hardware technology that's
very good at for example calculating
graph relations comparable with like G
what GPUs are doing for machine
learning, right? Or those kind of
things. So that's at the bottom layer.
It's very abstract, but it's hardware
and that hardware helps you to
accelerate search. On top of that you
have the the infrastructure and the or
the the deep tech infrastructure if you
will. So that is where the databases
mostly sit like so that's the example
that we just talked about where NOPJ
sits that's where we sit and those kind
of things they add value from a
functional perspective
and then on top of that you have the use
case startups and the use case
businesses so they solve a specific
problem. So there was for example the
demo that Panos gave was a great example
of that right. So you see that there's a
specific use case, specific need in the
market and that is what's being shown. I
what I know from experience is that
you have different types of investors
for for these three different types in
the market. So you cannot ask from
snowflake for for for sake of argument
what's your use case because the the on
the use case level because the thing is
if you just have a lot of data and you
want to stare that store that in a
persistent data warehouse then you need
us. It's a functional thing. It's a
functional problem that they solve. So
what I've learned from experience is
that um on the lowest level with the in
with the infrastructure, the investors
who sit there ask very sophisticated
questions like um uh um so who's using
this? How much can you improve it? Is
there a need for the speed improvement?
Uh those kind of things
go to market.
>> No, no, no, no, no. I I think the lower
No, I I disagree with that. So the lower
you go in the stack, the less important
the go to market becomes.
>> Mhm.
>> Because the thing is if you are able to
prove that you're creating hardware
silicon that is improving these graph
calculations
but you go like yeah sorry but it's like
it's three years go to market and I I I
don't know yet what that means. The
investors who are sophisticated in that
layer they don't care. They go like they
see it, they understand it and they
>> No. Yeah. True. True. when you raise
your seat down, you don't have to do
that, right? But you need still to be
able to understand some
how you're going to also make the case
in front of people because there are so
many great technologies that never find
adoption because the founders cannot uh
demonstrate but there on the hardware
it's quite interesting. we
in a company doing FPGA acceleration and
to be honest you know it's kind of
difficult sometimes to in this noise
environment
>> to make performance gains uh sought
after like you know some that's why you
need specific very good investors that
have a lot of money to keep investing in
this endeavor for a very long time to to
be able to
>> to find your first customers
>> yeah I I I some through that. Yeah,
>> just to add to um to what you're um
debating let's say about I have a very
specific actually a number of very
specific use cases to uh to reference
there and some of them we actually
hosted earlier in one of our sessions.
So one of our sessions was precisely
about that uh graph processing on the
hardware level and we had people from uh
Sananova uh we had people from graph
core and a couple of uh other companies
as well who specialize in precisely that
making optimized hardware for processing
uh graph uh graph operations and as far
as I know as far as I've been able to uh
to talk with uh executives from from all
of these companies and actually there's
a bunch more, not not just the ones that
we hosted. There's there's more that's
just popping up by the day almost. And
what I what I [snorts] observe is that
well people funds who invest in those
seem to somehow to um to add to um to uh
to support actually Bob's argument, they
seem to be focused on that specific uh
on that specific area. So they
understand very well that you know even
what may seem like um marginal let's say
improvement today uh could be actually a
big deal if you apply that uh at scale.
>> Yeah. And and a case in point there is
the GPU. So what is the GPU nowadays
used for the most machine learning
training and uh um uh um uh everything
related to blockchain and
cryptocurrency. What does the G and GPU
mean? graphical processing unit. So when
it was created, it had the focus on
processing like you know calculating the
triangles in in in showing 3D graphics
and and if I may uh if I may quickly
finish my my thought about like the the
the stack the so so yeah what because we
were talking about the hardware then on
top of that so this is where I kind of
know that's where I sit so I know the
most about the deep tech people are you
interest or sorry the investor interest
in the horizontal scalability So like
and I don't mean no not scalability the
horizontal applications. So the more
different companies that you can find
that use your technology
shows how valuable it is. So if you have
insurance companies, financial com uh uh
companies uh uh startups uh uh uh
chemicalbased whatever you can think of
using your technology that shows the the
broad applicability and then on that
layer above that's the use case um u
layer. So where you just for example
have a graphical user interface where
people use it then I believe it becomes
very important early on to show that go
to market because then you are very
specific about your use case and then
the question becomes how much are people
willing to pay for that. But if you are
lower in that stack and you just show
the value and a lot of people using it
then that is that then that creates
interest in the investors who are
knowledgeable about that specific space.
>> Let me maybe a few words about this. Y
sure
>> I think it's significantly depends on
type of the market. So you don't need to
show go to market at develop at hardware
level or middleware level but you need
to show that the market is big because
obviously if you develop hardware which
is greater than current GPUs and TPUs in
terms of machine learning processing
then it's fine you definitely will find
some good funding. The same for quantum
computers which we invested by the way.
If you create
working quantum computer with
>> with meaningful amount of cubits and
they are working and so on you have
something to show at least at your lab
laboratory then it's fine. definitely
will find good market and because a lot
of governments already committed
billions of dollars for quantum programs
and we maybe we'll never know uh for
sure I mean if we will see a real world
applications of quantum computing in the
next 10 years but we definitely know
that there is budget for next 10 years
that's why for example we see company
like inq right now it's a public company
worth I think around four or five
billion dollar which has zero sales and
has no working quantum computer yet, but
it's already worth billions because
people believe that there is market for
such kind of solutions. But we're
talking about hardware for graph
database processing. Well, I'm not sure
even if you develop the best hardware in
this particular niche that it makes a
lot of sense in terms of a meaning
because this market niche is is more
narrow than let's say quantum computing
or machine learning applications. So it
all depends about on size of the market
and people's people beliefs about its
size in the future at least.
>> Yes. So I sorry go ahead.
>> Yeah I was just going to say that well
um you know I'm just relaying basically
here the uh the arguments of the people
building uh graph centered hardware but
uh their ar their main point is that
well basically at the compiler level
everything is a graph operation. So uh
by optimizing this you make you make
hardware that's that can accelerate
everything. You know I'm simplifying it
as much as possible.
Yeah and and that is that is exactly my
point. So the where where the where the
the graph operation adds the value in
that stack. So um the hardware deep tech
or the on the functionality layer is
completely different. So what I notice
and I don't know if you guys notice that
as well but on the on the top layer if
people talk about graph they talk about
the visualization of the graph that they
want to see it. If you talk at the
lowest level, we talk about um u um
graph operations in for example on C CPU
level or a machine learning model,
right? That's also some form of a graph.
So that you somehow want to optimize uh
which is not per se very visible and
then on our layer it's just unless that
you're dealing with things like time
series and those kind of things. the
fact that we decided to create VV8 in a
um and have a graph data model that was
just that may just the reason not to do
that I mean there's enough computing
power to do it so why not just do that
and
so so the point I want to make with this
is that in these different layers the
role of the graph and where the graph
adds value is different and uh and I I I
think that should be that's something
that that we should to um um should
think about and the so maybe even should
acknowledge when we talk about where the
value of these graph-based technologies
uh is added.
>> Okay. So we kind of danced [snorts]
around let's say the uh the topic of how
how big this this market is or even how
how to define it and well Bob you
provided one one way to to look at
things by uh this three layer stack
let's say and depending if you adopt
this view you may choose to to address
uh the the market the associated markets
actually in in a similar way so let's
say the the hardware market and the deep
tech market and then the uh applications
let's a uh market. That's one way of of
looking at things. The other way would
be to approach it as a kind of in the
kind of uh technology segmentation let's
say that we initially adopted in this uh
connected data uh world look at look at
things. So the graph database market
then the knowledge graph market the uh
the graph machine learning market and uh
the uh semantic technology market.
That's another another way of looking at
things. It all depends on on the lens
you choose. Whatever lens you choose, uh
let's generalize a little bit. How would
you well actually the lens that you
choose does make uh does play a role
because it um it kind of dictates let's
say uh what what sources you would be
looking at. So I would like to address
this question to all of you and you can
take turns as you uh as you please u
answering it. So, what are your go-to
sources if you want to uh evaluate,
let's say, um or get a feeling of uh how
how big this this market is?
>> Would you?
>> Well, let let me give some simple
answer. For most of the markets we
consider investing investments
uh it's pretty obvious that the markets
are large enough. So we don't even need
to
uh collect a lot of data because it's
obviously that if you building let's say
data warehouse then the market is huge.
uh the same for most of things uh we
consider. There are some uh specific
areas for example like quantum computing
which is not obvious current moment and
then well we just talk with a lot of
experts of the market trying to
understand uh what kind of budgets would
be available in the next five or 10
years maybe by by governments or by
enterprises or maybe by consumers in
different areas.
>> Okay. So it sounds like your um primary
way of uh evaluation in that case is in
a way doing your own research. So uh
talking to uh to people um who may be
potential users.
>> Uh yeah but by the end of the day I mean
uh well if you can see just Gardner
report about some market and it shows
that it's say5 billion dollar then as a
VC you don't really care if it's correct
number or wrong. you care more about,
let's say, order of magnitude of this
number. I mean, it could be three or
seven. You don't really care. You care
that it's much higher than 1 billion
dollar.
>> Mhm.
>> And it's enough big market to create a
valuable company in this market. If
things will go well, uh I think you know
we are not interested so much in how big
is the market when you start. The
question is you know how big is the
market when you exit, right? So in seven
eight years something will be extremely
different. So if you go back and look at
infrastructure like you know let's say
new graph database I think what really
matters is adoption like open source
adoption how you can actually create a
vibrant community and how you can
diversify versus everything else. Um so
sometimes you know people are just
taking like a Java database application
and then they rewrite it in C and
they're claiming that it's going to be
30% cheaper to operate.
uh that's a great feature but it's not
like a winning feature. A winning
feature is like to do something in a
very different way. If you see for
example other parts of the of the market
of data market you will see for example
how now everything is becoming like a
stream even likedms now they are
materialized using streams. So it's a
different way to do something more
traditional uh which is quite
interesting. So there I think you know
you need to have a huge edge versus you
know the incumbents a new way to do
things and of course show that the
market resonates with you and when I
make markets I mean developer adoption
essentially right now on the application
that's where things can get more
interesting because there are some very
narrow markets so someone somebody is
using I don't know a graph at the base
application just to analyze uh 10
proteins and just this 10 proteins
because they apply I don't know in uh
some I don't know food production
Maybe that's a small market, right? Uh
but they may have like a plan to to go
much bigger. They might want to be able
to analyze or chemicals are going into
food or cosmetics or anything else and
create like a virtual solution for a
market. Uh also we see you know what uh
founders are starting with is just you
know opening up their appetite uh and
eventually they expand and expand. It's
very important to know that you know
they can nail a market first even a
narrow one in a niche market and I think
it's more important to start with a
niche market and find love in the market
that people don't go back to the life
before using your tool and then you can
go and adjusted markets and win over. Uh
we have seen it again and again. Uh so
the question is not about how big is the
market now. How the question the the the
question is how big is going to be in
the future and what are the changes that
going to enabling this market to 10x or
100x in the future as I said before uh
in my previous uh comment. Uh what we
see right now as a make as a huge
enabler for graph the basis is
remodeling the world analyzing existing
corpuses and breaking down into more and
more relationship that before with
previous technology wasn't possible. Um
so yeah I think you know it's it's not
going to be like a dedicated let's say
segment of the market like in a way it
might be as big as the that market is
right now.
>> Yeah. So um somebody mentioned the uh I
think it was you consenting somebody
mentioned the the magic word uh gardener
and predictions and all that. So it's a
very good segue for me to share
something that I wanted to uh to share.
>> If I may sh I would love to also add add
an answer there if I if I may. Mhm.
>> Y yeah.
So quickly before because what's
interesting from the from the other two
guests here is like looking at it from
the perspective of a an investor. Um but
I'm of course looking at it from a
perspective of a of a startup making new
technology
>> and I I think so I you have a different
point of view to the in your business
development towards the market because
the thing that you've created that's
your starting point that's what you need
to work with and so what we have done is
that we said like okay what we can do we
so we use machine learning to identify
these graph notes in the graph as I just
shared in the Wikipedia um demo and then
the question becomes like so where does
that add a lot of value and then you
make a few assumptions. So for example
in fast move consumer goods in in the
medical space in insurance finance and
those kind of things you create a use
case on top of that in the three
sections that I mentioned in the topper
in the higher layer and you try to find
users or customers there. users is a
little bit different when you have open
source software like us because they
often find you but you also try to find
customers. So what you can do with these
kind of deep technologies is that you
can assume a use case.
You show that to the end users and then
probably you often you're like a little
bit wrong but then it's like well you
can do it like this or you can do it
like that. And at some point on a
horizontal level you start to just get
in all these different use cases from
all these different um um uh uh uh
industries and that's what we have. So
we have currently uh uh a few hundred
use cases in 18 industries and that is
just for one technology and that's how
that's how we do it. So you just make an
assumption. and you say like I think
that in a medical space I don't know a
hospital could add value by using wevier
by doing XYZ and then you just ask
people like would this adds value and
then if they say yes then you build on
top of that and um what we also see is
that when you create something new so
with in these uh ML in in graphs like
what we are doing is that you also see a
lot of inbound coming in at some point
but not at the beginning but the people
already figured that
and then they always seem to fit in
these pillars that you already
identified. So that's uh I don't know if
this is helpful for anybody on listening
but that's how we do it. Yeah,
>> it probably is. Uh I hope it is [snorts]
and uh thanks thanks for sharing. So
just to um to validate basically what
all of you I think have been saying each
of you in their own way uh about uh well
about not not necessarily being very
specific but uh being able to uh to see
the trends and kind of um kind of create
a ballpark let's say estimate of of
where this is going. So if there is one
uh analyst house that is uh famous for
for doing that that would be Gartner and
again to um to tie everything uh that
you've said together I think uh the way
that they framed it like uh graph
relates everything is a is a very uh is
a very good uh phrase a very nice uh way
of putting that let's say so these are
the Gartner top 10 data and analytics
trends for 2021
and as you can see uh well under the um
distributed everything uh moniker they
have this graph relates everything. So
to expand a little bit uh on that um uh
they have given a number of uh
predictions. So uh and actually not just
predictions but also let's say anecdotal
evidence based on uh feedback that they
get from from their customers. So uh
their prediction is that uh by the year
2025 uh they expect to see something
like I think they said 80% uh increase
in the current uh level of uh use for
for graph databases. So that's uh that's
quite huge actually uh and uh they they
sort of attribute that to the interest
that they see uh from queries from their
customers. So uh one of their uh market
uh research leaders uh has mentioned
that uh today uh already something like
50% of their inbound uh queries uh for
uh for new technologies are about graph
in in one way or another and that's up
from uh 10% I think a couple of years uh
back and so to them that's uh that's
evidence that uh the need that the
realization that uh people need graph
more and more is is settling in is is
sinking in and this is why that they
have upgraded let's say uh graph to uh
to an up and front and up and coming uh
technology in their uh predictions and
they're uh they're betting uh heavily uh
on that as well and for uh people like
uh myself actually who have been into
that uh and into that technology for uh
for a while it's sort of uh as as the
colleague said it's sort of a
vindication let's say. So you invest in
something early on and uh then you see
it uh paying off. So investment in the
more general sense not necessarily in
term of uh capital investment but also
time and interest and all of those uh
things. So um would you say do you see
um and that's mostly a question for uh
the uh investors in uh in the group. So
do you see that playing out also in the
uh in the pitches that that you get? So
do um do you see more people knocking on
your doors um whether they are
representing deep tech companies or use
case companies that utilize graph in one
way or another.
Yeah, definitely. I for last I think uh
half a year I talk with many companies
in data sphere and many of them are
using graphs of developing new graphs.
So I could name a few which I found
quite interesting. One of them is a
company called Terminos DB. Uh another
one is Vatical which was the formerly
named Graen which tried which started as
graph database. Now they developing uh
type uh strongly type database not only
graph but some kind of declarative
language
using uh advantages of graph
technologies and I see more and more
coming uh it's really I think we are at
the point when the world become became
very complex and you can't properly
analyze that amount of data which was
generated without graph technology. It
was not true for let's say last 10 years
but it's true I tell
>> what about you panos have you been
getting more pitches from a uh whether
it's graph companies directly or graph
use case companies
>> mostly we haven't seen any graph uh
infrastructure graph uh database company
uh but to be honest uh we on even the
application level like you know I don't
think it's a good idea like in Europe to
say we're using graph or we are using
whatever xyz technology that's something
that uh
uh it's something you you we prefer like
to discuss you when we're doing let's
say the deep dive on the product and the
technology and we see like you know how
well verse people are actually like to
solve the problem right um the
technology let's say is the lesser part
right if you are actually good
technologist then I will show in a
conversation you're going to create
something that people love it to use it
right so if your secret source that is a
graph database because your development
and your quering can be faster or you
have a better understanding of the
modeling of the problem. Uh that's
that's really shows at the end of the
day in the application you develop if
we're talking about the use case, right?
So it becomes like it fades in the
background, right? And I think you know
that's will be the success for the
industry and not to be raising it as an
exotic flag in trying to to lure
investors by using like a hide word like
blockchain or AI or graph interface
right the problem is that you actually
solve the problem very nicely and your
end users are really excited about the
way you do it that's that's what really
matters
>> sure I mean I would I would definitely
agree with you on the um on how you
frame the issue let's say I was for uh
referring. Okay. So, yes, people people
should should should frame it in the way
you uh you approach it basically. But
having gotten having gotten the framing
out of the way, do you see uh people
solving interesting problems and
approaching them you know in a nice way
for the for the users actually using
that kind of technology?
>> Yes. Yes. We have seen we have seen as
as described causally we have seen
another one in the blockchain space that
we didn't invest for other reasons that
they were also using graph databases and
we have a small portfolio only 16
investments so far and uh two of them
already using graph database and there
might be another cyber security one
that's going to use as well uh and the
cyber security again is a very very
interesting space for applications on
top of craft databases
>> okay so three out of 16 is probably an
interesting uh interesting ratio
>> if we're going to do this investment.
Yeah.
>> Sure. Sure.
>> It it seems it's becoming more
mainstream from anecdotal data.
>> All right.
Right. And speaking of uh anecdotal
data, here's something else I'd [snorts]
like to uh to share with you. again in
the uh in the spirit of trying to
approximate let's say how big this
market could uh possibly be. So this is
anecdotal data uh by all means and this
is why I'm not going to uh to uh to
trace it uh back [snorts] to uh to a
source. Um it's basically uh it's based
on um kind of numbers flying around
let's say in a way but uh it tries to
approximate uh the um total addressable
uh market for graph databases uh for
some reason actually uh because of the
fact that uh the people that uh did this
work started uh with it uh before COVID
and they um got uh caught up in the uh
this whole COVID situation like all of
us and so they um they did uh two
estimates uh one precoid and one
postcoid and as you can see uh this uh
this chart is in uh million dollars. So
their projection is that um this uh
market started uh worth uh in in 2018
and it was worth something like $850
million and then it grew in 2019. it
grew a little bit more in 2020 and 21.
And so by that rate of growth their
estimate is that uh by 2026 it will be
worth around four or five billion dollar
I guess which you know in the in the
greater scheme of things may not be uh
that much but um as [snorts] I think
some of you pointed out earlier what
you're trying to get into this uh into
this game is not in an exact number but
uh more like an estimate more like a
size of uh what this market uh could be
worth. Does that resonate with you? Does
does that make sense to you depend based
on on on your own feeling of the market?
>> Yeah, I think so. The numbers look
reasonable enough.
>> Mhm.
>> I think we'll know when you know one of
the big vendors IPOs. we're gonna have a
much better understanding of the market.
>> But we need to wait till I think 2026 to
really figure it out.
>> Fair enough.
>> Neo forj I guess it's in a it's in a
stage that they could go public a bit
earlier.
>> Yeah, actually Neoforj is um you know
it's a is a good is a good talking point
basically for for a number of uh
reasons. I think uh they raised money I
think actually twice in uh in the in the
recent months and so their uh initial so
they had two funding rounds in 2021
already. Their first one was if my
memory served me right something like
$350 million which uh on their own
account is was the uh the largest ever
funding round in the database uh space.
So I guess that that says something and
their valuation is now well over a
billion. So I guess that puts them in
unicorn territory and and so on. So
by most people's accounts and you know
these things are quite uh quite sicky.
They are the the leaders in this market.
So that that probably shows that
probably tells us something about uh the
uh the overall growth in the market
there. But even when Neo forj will
become a public company, we still be
thinking more about expectations about
the market not real market size. The
company already mentioned today IMQ
which is doing quantum computing. It's
worth billions of dollars but there is
almost no market for quantum computing
right now. It's all about some future
estimations.
>> Yeah. But I I I really think that is
that is kind of mixing up stuff, right?
So I mean if you look at a relational
database
the the relational fact the fact that it
has the word relational in there assumes
that you can make graph relations just
turns out that the way that these
databases are built uh that al that
joining of tables that doesn't work very
well. So this is a specific problem that
NORJ has solved which is great and good
for them. But I think
the looking at the market from the
perspective of saying like graph
databases like for example NFJ
is really I think missing the bigger
point of linked data and I think the
bigger point is that we've gotten to a
to a to a to a point in time where
thanks to all the CPU powers the the the
the amount of memory the amount of GPUs
that we have available with the big
cloud providers means that we can
finally
use whatever tool we need to build stuff
uh uh to make linked data solutions and
I think that's the bigger thing. So I I
think the overarching thing is that
connecting no pun intended connecting uh
uh linked data to what the size of the
market is of graph databases
is I think missing the point. I think
the the bigger point is like do we see
the market as a whole move towards link
data and I think that we can say yes it
is and uh
with the exception maybe of time series
data name me a startup that is not
looking at their data from the
perspective of linked data anymore.
I I I really from my colleagues I can't
think of any. If the if you're an IoT,
you look at it as a big graph. If you do
blockchain stuff, you look at it as a
big graph. And why can you do that?
Because the uh we're getting we got to a
point in time where the technology sorry
the hard drive became good enough or
fast enough to represent everything as
graphs. That's the big difference with
like 10 years ago or something. So I I I
understand the sentiment also what
you're trying to show with the with the
graph George but I think it's just it
it's it's magnitudes bigger because
everybody's looking going into the
direction let me give you a practical
example so what is the second thing that
snowflake is offering besides their data
warehouse that is connecting data
relating data to each other
I dare to bet you a nice bottle of wine
that they're looking at that from the
perspective of link data [laughter]
and if they're going to be successful in
that I don't care what database they use
or kind of way they use to visualize it.
It's just the world is moving towards
that big vision that also uh um web 3.0
and I don't mean the
>> blockchain 3.0 but the previous 3.0
[laughter]
>> the semantic web 3.0 had it's moving in
that direction. I think the big thing
that has changed and that was what I was
trying to show with my demo is that
we try to solve that and we being
humanity try to solve that problem by
somehow trying to agree on definitions
in the semantics has changed to like you
know what let the machine u uh the the
machine learning model figure it out and
that was such an an an epiphany and an
eye openener that it became easier to
connect these nodes in these graphs
together.
Going back to my point,
name somebody um who isn't building a
startup um that that is not making graph
legends anymore.
Quick asterisk if your startup really
relies. So for example, what Pana showed
us in like shortest paths and those kind
of things, of course, you're going to
choose Neo forj because NORAJ is good at
showing shortest paths in nodes in a
graph. But you could even argue that if
you store your data in uh MongoDB that
these individual data objects are nodes
that you connect to each other, it's
just not very good at the computations
that NEOJ is doing, but it's good at
other computations. But it it's for me a
no-brainer that the market is just
moving in the direction of connecting
everything together and and which is way
bigger than just looking at it from the
perspective of a graph database. Sure.
It it depends very much on, you know, on
how you look at things. If you're graph,
people tend to uh to see connections
everywhere and they tend to see
everything as as a graph. So, it's makes
sense. And just to um to add to to your
point and actually we have a question
comment from Katarina in uh in the chat.
So, um I think well the the comment part
is that well she see she agrees with uh
the point you're making Bob that uh well
it's um [snorts]
trying to pick one particular segment
and look at it in in isolation may be
helpful because it sort of helps you
narrow down the scope and it makes it
more more feasible let's say to uh to do
these projections and come up with these
numbers but it may be misleading in the
in the ter in the in the sense that well
it's uh in the sense that graph is
everywhere basically. So trying to to
narrow it down maybe um yeah not not the
uh not a very uh wise thing to do. Uh
but
the comment the the question part from
from Kadarin is that well so fine we
we've talked a lot about graph databases
and by the way the the reason we did it
is basically because um there seems to
be more data around this particular
sector you know all these projections
and um hype estimations and and all
those things but Katern is making an
interesting uh question so what about
other uh graphy let's say uh products
and uh parts of the market. So what
about graph visualization for example or
uh things like uh data modeling editors?
Are those in your radar at all? Do you
see any any interest or uptake in those?
>> Yeah, that's a great question. Uh I
think it goes in tandem with uh overall
adoption of databases. The more data
that is there, the more need for these
kind of tools emerges. Uh so for example
you know nobody will imagine 15 years
ago that PHP my admin will be a product
right. So right now we have a magnitude
of products that just give you like
search SQL uh notebooks where you can
share your queries and view the data and
uh some of these companies now they are
raising they have sorry they have
reached unicorn status just for allowing
companies to reshare SQL queries and
preview your data and collaborate on top
of your data. I guess something similar
will happen. Now the question is if it's
going to be a dedicated product or it's
going to be part of this uh data
workbook collaboration tools that we
already exist and they using and they
are built on top of relational
databases. Uh so do we need another
point solution or we need a broader
solution and some of the big ones is
going to to expand. Similarly I guess we
might need to see things like uh
governance
uh access control uh to expanding to
graph databases. uh my take is that some
startup will emerge to address the there
is the issue and very quickly it will be
acquired by a more established company
in the space that they also want to
cover the emerging use case of gra
databases so definitely a place of
interest now if it's going to be really
big I think it's a bit n in the broader
realm of data management right or data
access and BI usually like data
visualization it's like another feature
in a broader BI my tool when talking
when we're talking about visualization,
but it might be a good run. It might be
a good run.
>> If I may if I may weigh in specifically
on the visualization part, well, you're
right. I mean, there's a bunch there's a
tone actually of uh BI and visualization
tools out there already. However, there
may be some some specific needs, let's
say, and some specific um some
peculiarities about visualizing graphs.
Uh which has to do with the fact that
well, it's it's a less explored area. Uh
by now, you know, visualizing, I don't
know, tables and uh pie charts and and
whatnot has been, you know, over
overused even. Uh visualizing graphs on
the other hand, not so much. And I would
also, you know, this and this is a
personal opinion. I think this is it's
it may also be harder to to crack that
nut because if you've ever tried
visualizing a large enough graph, uh you
know that gets very [snorts] messy very
quickly. So, and I know that there
already are uh some specialized
companies that address this particular
need. Um how much you know there is room
for growth there? Yeah, I don't know
what what you said, Panos. May, you
know, it sounds to me like a reasonable
take. Eventually, probably someone will
want to uh to add them to their
portfolio when uh the need for that
becomes pronounced enough.
>> Constantine, what's what's your take? Uh
well yeah I'm thinking about
visualization of graph databases and uh
uh I think I don't think that there will
be a lot of big players on this
particular segment because if we think
about BI tools like PowerBI or Tableau
or other kind of things which allow
graphana which allows to have some kind
of dynamic dashboards and other kind of
visualization things. It all uh came
from
visualization which was static like
let's say PowerPoint slides or word
documents or something which existed
even on paper in pre computer era uh and
people use pie charts people used tables
other kind of visualization things but
people did not use a lot of graphs
frankly speaking and if you open current
Microsoft PowerPoint it's well you could
now embed some kind of graph like
structure but it's also you know it's
not a straightforward kind of tool and
my takeaway is just people don't use a
lot of graphs even simple one if if
we're not talking about very large
graphs which is quite hard to v
visualize but even about simpler ones so
I think that that if uh graph
visualization will be
will be actually popular it will be
let's say more domain specific and will
be more about some applications which
has specific way of vis visualizing
graphs in some particular area of of
knowledge and it will be very different.
I don't believe in general purpose graph
visualization tool as a standalone
valuable company.
>> Mhm. Okay. Um there's also something
else which is of interest even though it
at at this time it may it may seem niche
at first and that's uh the u we talked
so far about the uh visualization part
um from the uh from the user let's say
from the end user perspective so you
know you have a big uh data set and it's
graph shaped how do you visualize it and
how do you explore it there are a few
solutions for that around I know um
Karina's um uh question also has the
data modeler uh aspect uh in uh in in
it. So if you're a data modeler and you
know you are you are working on a on an
enterprise knowledge graph for example
the solutions that are available to you
uh at this point are well not you know
[snorts]
they not necessarily they don't
necessarily score very high on the
usability uh aspect. So, and I know that
that Katarina has that in mind because
she is a data modeler herself. So, do
you think there is a need to address
that? It's probably an even smaller
let's say uh subdomain than the one um
addressed to end users. But do you think
do you see that that's important? Do you
do you think that um it's something that
a few enterprises would be willing to
pay for for a good solution? uh I think
you know we have to look it like uh from
another perspective like I think you can
unlock a lot of uh value right by
abstracting a lot of developer work
right that's that's one of the kind of
solutions trying to do trying to remove
all the ground work uh everything you
will do like in your text editor and
pushing the code so the question is you
know can you actually create your models
and control them add the semantics
around the fields do governance, do the
line age as well, being able to do
enterprise connectors and start
populating in this new model the
entries. Uh all of this combined
together I think will be making for a
very compelling use case. For example,
we just exited from a company that was
doing pretty much what I described but
for streams on top of Kafka. So you know
they they had like a governance model
they had a schema registry you could
search for the meta fields you can look
at the data from the source during the
stream and in the sync right so
something similar that allows you to do
let's say all the ops all the operation
of starting from somewhere and go to a
functional database uh it's really
important it's like this productivity
layer on top of the of the database and
then you know there are different
solutions built on top. I think that's a
pretty exciting space.
>> Okay.
>> But you have to think not just like you
know the the narrow part of just doing
the model but everything around it. It's
government it's linets collaboration on
it how you feed it how you monitor the
quality of the data. I think when you if
you can do something like that it could
be a quite interesting uh use case.
Just to to tie that back to the previous
conversation on graph databases, we seem
to uh to coming to be coming back to
them constantly. But uh well so many of
them are actually trying to grow in this
direction that you're that you just
described P. So um go basically beyond
just well just uh store for for graph
data for graph data into uh more into
covering more and more of these areas.
So um adding visualization u
capabilities is one of the areas that
they're growing uh towards uh adding
some governance layer. [snorts] I
haven't I haven't seen that so much yet
but I know that some of them at least
would like to to go there. Uh helping
developer productivity is also something
that I see them addressing. So many of
them these days also come with their own
built-in integrated uh developer uh
environments uh tailored specifically to
the needs uh for uh of people developing
on on top of graph models. So it seems
that you know what what you're saying uh
resonates with with them on some level.
Um so Bob let me let me come back to you
um from you know to to give us your um
your view on the um on the from the
vendor let's say uh perspective. So when
people uh when you on board people to uh
to weiate how many of those things that
uh those requirements let's say that
Panos uh just mentioned um do people
address to you and how many of those are
you able to um uh to satisfy let's say.
>> Yeah. So that's a great question. So the
um
not a lot to be honest. So because the
reason that people on board to us is
that they want to solve that problem. So
um that can be a corporate that says
like okay there's nothing on the market
that we can now pick off the shelf that
really specifically fits our needs. So
we go a little bit deeper in the stack
and we start on a database level and
then build something on top of that or a
startup that says like hey we have an
idea to visualize something or work on
something
to um uh present it to the to the end
user and I'm a very strong believer when
it comes to these kind of things like if
you look at the stack and then again if
I may in my three sections the value of
your product sits somewhere. So it sits
in the top layer, it sits in the middle
layer or in the bottom layer. And I
think that's the most important thing to
to um to look at. So so for example, and
what I really liked about the point that
Kathrina was making is like I get that
for people who are doing the data
modeling that there's a need for that
kind of an interface.
I don't know from a value creation point
of view how much value specifically the
interface creates. it is more like how
that uh rest how it works together in
harmony with the database. So what you
just mentioned also George that you said
like we see more companies move in that
direction. Sure, if I would be if if I
would be tomorrow, snap of a finger, I
would be the CEO of Snop forJ, I would
do the same thing, of course, because
it's not hurting your business because
you know that the value of what you're
creating sits in the database and not
per se in how you're visualizing stuff
on top. And if people are have a unique
way of visualizing something on top of
your software, then you charge them. So
it's like it's the you see so that
that's how I look at it from a vendor
perspective that I'm a strong believer
that where we are right now the value
sits in actually being able to do the
data modeling and and with data modeling
I don't mean the visualization but the
the just the the raw computing power and
even especially when we include machine
learning to show the right results in a
few milliseconds that's the that is
where I think the most value is being
created right now and if you need the
specific way to visualize it. Sure, by
all means. But it's like I'm not sure
how much value that would add to my
business today.
>> Mhm. Okay. So, you think that um where
we are right now, it's getting it's it's
mostly about getting uh the basic, let's
say, and um well, visualization may be
um a bit out of your scope. uh at least
>> they're yes they're out of my scope but
I also really mean it from a value
creating perspective. So let let's take
that example that you because you you
made a very good point George and I know
some companies that you probably also
know that are really good at visualizing
these huge graphs like you take the
Facebook graph and they have technology
to actually make a visual for it. The
thing is
you first need to be able to get the
data out to know what to visualize
which goes down in the stack on the
lowest level. You need to have the CPU
and memory power to actually do that.
Now we now have that thanks to all the
big uh uh infrastructure companies. Then
on top of that you need to have the
databases or the search engines to
actually give you the coordinates and
the data points that you want to
visualize. And then on top of that you
might have some companies that actually
do the visualization.
Now
depends a little bit on why on on on per
company where the that actual value sits
because I know of a company that is
really good at showing these billion uh
node graphs in a visual. That's a hard
thing to solve. So their value sits in
the top layer. But if somebody says like
yeah I'm so the example that I just
showed you finding these notes in the
graph and if somebody would say I'm
going to make a graphical interface on
top of that to show these search results
that's great good for them but I'm not
sure how much value that is adding from
a monetary perspective.
>> Okay that's
[snorts]
I'm I'm not sure about that either. what
I do uh know what what I can relate to
you from um from experience basically
from from working with uh people in uh
in many organizations is that well
visualization does matter if you're
trying to convey the value that a use
case may bring to um to to enterprise
users for example yes I mean obviously
you know if it doesn't work on the on
the data modeling layer on the hardware
layer on all of those it's going to be
um it's your your use case is not going
to be practical. But no matter you know
how fast this is or you know how how
brilliant your data model is or you know
how you may elaborate on on all of those
things in a sort of abstract way. Uh to
repeat what Katarina said you know the
moment they they see it you know there's
this wow effect and they sort of get it.
So my two sense is that well yes I see
your point of view that visualization
couldn't exist without the underlying
layers but I think that it really
matters.
>> No no no so I I I I don't disagree with
that. It's more the point that I'm
trying to like the question is if that's
what where the value sits. So let's
let's take um let me give you a cheesy
example to make my point.
>> Cheesy example. Let's say you had like
Google search in the early days. So you
had like that that that famous white
page with just a few blue links on it
top layer the visualization.
>> Then you had the engine that that um the
founders of Google created to actually
show you the right results and then you
had the infrastructure that it was
running on. So let's say you show this
to an investor and yes you use that you
use that graphical interface
to show it. So these this very clear
overview that Google still has today.
It's a little more fancy now but makes
my point. And now just as a thought
experiment you would ask an investor do
you like this? And then an investor
would say this is fantastic because I
can now search the web. And then you
would ask the investor, okay, but you're
allowed to invest in one thing or in the
graphical interface that Google has or
in the technology and the database that
they created to show these results or in
the hardware that it's running on then I
think that every investor would jump on
the database that they created like you
know it's like yes the the interface is
intuitive but
the value
>> chicken and deck problem frankly
speaking because uh I mean Google is
full stack right it's about database
it's about page rank algorithm it's
about search engine page and so on and
when Google appeared it was not the
first search engine on the market and
people already knew how it could work
and how what is final use case for
people who are using search and that
it's valuable and then Google introduced
some better algorithm better database
and so on which actually people well let
me put in that simple way people do not
need graph databases. They need to solve
problems. And uh if you know that graph
database could solve real problems, then
well people will invest in graph
database as a technology.
>> I need to need to show how it could
could solve real world problems first.
>> Yeah, but I I disagree with that
proposition because that's saying like
people don't need water, they're just
thirsty, right? So the the the the the
thing is like the Google is well known
for the graph that they created and it I
I'm I'm just I'm just I'm also a little
bit surprised about this because I'm
like you you mentioned page rank which
of course nowadays is rank brain. If I
if you could choose to invest in the
design that they created the interface
when you do Google search which I'm not
complicating about because I'm I'm sorry
complaining about because I'm using that
on a on a daily basis myself
or as an investor I had to invest in
rank brain for me
>> depends on timing
>> it's I I mean it's it's very easy to you
know to connect dots looking backward
but it's very hard to do when you try to
look forward it's very hard I mean to
understand such kind of things when
you're in 1992
it's easy right now to understand what
was it better investment or worse
investment but it's not that clear when
you don't see real applications of this
technology because if you remember there
are a lot of uh misconceptions about
possible technology for example let's
mention very famous quote of Bill Gates
about that I think 4 kilobytes of memory
will be enough for everybody and uh and
so on. I mean this is and it it was
quoted by the guy who already knew
applications and still uh at that moment
it look like it's I mean we don't need
enough we don't need very strong
technology in this particular segment 4
kilobyt is enough now we know that it's
was because well people produce
a lot of data they need a lot of memory
to process this data
and the same for all other technologies
I mean you need to see real applications
only then you're comfortable and
confident about investing in
technologies which will further improve
these applications. People know how to
search in the in the web before Google
appeared. That's why it was very
available to invest in Google.
>> Yes, I'm I'm not saying I disagree with
you, but from me being on the other side
of the table in this conversation, I
like to poke the investors here. So you
could also argue you could also argue
that what you just said you're using
your own words you could also said like
if you need to see it first before
believing it you might be too late.
>> Uh you you need to see a real world
applications could be applications uh
based on different technology. We don't
need to you know uh we know that the
world need to compute something uh and
that's enough uh to invest in quantum
computing while we can see real world
evidence that quantum computing works
for to solve business problems but we
know that classic computing works that's
enough for us is yeah I think but that's
that's like the catch 22 for you right
so the you know the computing needs to
happen but ideally you would also see
like to see a great quantum computing
application it's always about yeah it's
question 22 what chicken you can problem
I mean it's always about you know you
need to you would like to know
everything and you as a venture investor
you always knew just very small uh area
of data you would like to to know
actually you always have to make
decisions in
certain substances
>> I think it is a catch 22 so if you are
and it's in some ways I see it as a sort
of leap of faith I mean If there were
already enough, you know, applications,
tangible applications that you could
see, then it means that maybe you're a
bit late in this market, then if there's
none, there's, you know, the element of
risk. But that's that's how investors
live, I guess. You know, that's that's
your bread and butter.
What about you, Puns? Just to uh to
round to um to to to round up this uh
this round of questions. So what where
would you invest the um the bottom
layer, the middle layer or the
application layer in in Bob's uh Google
example, the visualization layer? Sorry.
>> Um I will invest everywhere, right? But
you know there are different attributes
when you're looking to different layers.
U should be honest if someone comes up
with a new database implementation if
there's no real traction I don't care.
It might be like an amazing algorithm
but if you can't create a community
around it it still doesn't matter. Now
where you have already foundation
already like big players in the in the
space but the adoption may be a bit
slow. So the example I gave to Katarina
before around creating like the solution
which is what I will describe as the
workbench where you describe your
models, you do your modeling, you can
bring your data in, you can visualize,
you can monitor, you can monitor the
quality and execution. Uh the middle
layer is something I really really like
and our our investment lenses on top of
Kafka proved that. Uh so we're very
happy with the results and there's
actually a few more investments that
took in in similar products that were
announced this week by Excel. Um and the
application layer of course is uh
another one but I don't think that the
application layer it matters. It gives
you perhaps a good uh indication that
you know the technology team is on top
of it that they really know how to
tackle the problem. Uh but it won't
guarantee any success. the fact that
they chose graph B over any other new
technology, right? Then there are
different factors in play there.
>> Okay, so let's have one final round of
um questions from uh and answers to
those questions from from all of you and
wrap this up. We're almost out of time
and it it just flew by. So since this is
the um this is time for wrap-up, let's
do a little bit of uh forwardlooking um
yeah guesses, speculations, whatever it
is you you want to call it. So where do
you see I think we'll probably all agree
that this market is growing. So let's
let's first see if my my assumption
resonates with you that well we agree
that this is going to grow and then uh
where where do you see the uh the
challenges and opportunities and where
do you think uh this market will be you
know typical kind of projection question
so where do you think this market will
be in let's say five years from now we
talked earlier I think about 2026 so
let's let's pick that as our uh
guesstimate
who wants to go
Hello. Uh I guess we're going to see the
first IPO in the space most likely being
Neo forj. Uh we already now have let's
say a solid set of vendors that are big
enough and well financed like to further
build the foundation of the market
namely Tiger Graph, Draft and Then we
see things like Neptune from AWS
and so on. uh most likely we're going to
see uh further proliferation in
developer adoption thanks to GraphQL
with its own issues when it comes to
that but I think it's going to be a net
positive uh to on board more people on
graph theory and graph databases
uh we're going to see an explosion of
adoption uh thanks to being able to
model the real world and take existing
data sets and reinterpret them or
interpret them for the first time ever
as graphs. Uh, and I think it'll be
quite bullish to see something emerging
on this middle layer we just described.
So, in order to make every everyone's
life easier and faster to work with
>> if you're working on something like
that, I would like to talk to you.
>> Well, you you just mentioned earlier
that uh you were actually able to find
at least the first uh well, let's say
graph related company in your portfolio
on your own. So now that you uh that you
made your head start, well, it's
probably easier for for people to find
you as well. So yeah,
>> thank you.
[gasps]
What do you think?
>> Well, I expect a new wave of
applications based on graph technology.
Um I could give you some simple example.
Take a look at CRM. So initially it was
on premise, then it was in the cloud
like Salesforce. Then everybody talks
about AI and Salesforce for example
acquired company related IQ. uh many
years ago and I think the next let's say
version of the CRM of the future would
be not just uh some kind of tool which
aggregates the maybe predict something
but actually this is some kind of
algorithm working on limited set of data
because there is limited set of people
and enterprises in the world and this is
a graph and I expect to see more um
applications like this in different
areas not only in sales But pl could be
plenty of other industries. But because
I mean we have enough computing power,
we have hardware, we have a lot of
things and we have proper data
structures like graph databases. Now we
could uh actually implement applications
for very large but limited data uh data
sets and we could uh probably it will be
one the final phase of let's say how it
could like because when you have well
let's say you you don't need to put uh
some small leads some kind of leads in
CRM but you have let's say graph with
all people in the world and all entities
in the world and you just need you don't
don't need to add you just need to
select something in in the in the graph
and it could be probably the final
possible data structure for many
applications. You just don't need to
add, you just select.
>> Okay. Thank you, Conarin. And Bob, what
about you? What what do you think will
be in five years from now?
>> I think five years from now, if I just
look at my crystal ball,
>> uh there will be another connected data
London event. It's like remember five
years ago this guy was here talking
about vectors [laughter]
in graphs and look where they are now.
So no but to be serious like I really
believe in that. So I and of course I'm
highly biased but I believe in the fact
that that mixing of machine learning
into the graph it there's so much value
coming from that and that's what we see
in the use cases. So I think that five
years from now that's that's going to be
a no-brainer. I really think that.
>> Okay.
Fair enough. Well, thank you all
gentlemen for uh for um coming along and
uh having this conversation. And like I
said, I hope it was interesting for you.
It certainly was for me. It just uh flew
by. We're almost to 2 hours uh here by
now and I didn't even realize. So,
thanks for uh staying with us this late
and I hope it was uh enjoyable for you
as well as uh the audience. And well uh
as I said feel free to check our
upcoming sessions as well. Uh if you uh
if you feel like uh hanging around a
little bit longer there is one more uh
there's actually three more coming up uh
after this one and then we start again
tomorrow uh around uh noon and then
there's the final day on Friday. Thank
you all very much and uh see you around.
Have a good evening. Bye-bye.
>> Bye.